[Music]
prices in the Bay Area market are insane
no other way to put it
[Music]
you
I chose to live in an industrial space
at the time because I couldn't really
find a room to rent everything was
really competitive and at the prices I
was finding for a room I could have
lived in an industrial space for the
same price if not less and have more
space to do the things that I enjoy
doing
[Music]
I have received an eviction notice they
want me out January 3rd they don't want
anybody living here we can still work
there's about four or five people that
work in the space including myself I
could still work here but I can't live
here to me the solution would be to work
with people in spaces like this and make
it so that it's safe for them to stay
there
you